Xavier is calibrating sophisticated
medical imaging equipment the manual
reports that the tangent of a particular
angle is one so that's saying that the
tangent let's say that that particular
angle is theta is equal to one what
should Javier do to find the angle and I
encourage you to pause this video and
look at these choices and think about
which of these should he do to find the
angle so let's look through each of them
so the first one well actually instead
of looking the choices let's think about
what we would do to find the angle so
this thing that the tangent of some
angle is equal to one well one thing
that you might want to do is say okay
let's just say if we take the inverse
tangent if we take the inverse tangent
of the tangent of theta so if we take
the inverse tangent of both sides of
this we of course would get the inverse
tangent of the tangent of theta if the
domain over here is restricted
appropriately is just going to be equal
to theta so that we can say the tangent
the theta is going to be the inverse
tangent of one so it might be tempting
to just pick this one right over here
type inverse tangent of one into his
calculator so maybe maybe this looks
like this looks like the best choice but
remember I said if we restrict the
domain right over here if we restrict
the possible values of tangent of theta
here appropriately then this is going to
simplify to this but there is a scenario
where this does not happen and that's as
if we pick Thetas that are outside of
the range of the inverse tangent
function now what do I mean by that
what's really just based on the idea
that there's multiple angles that have
there are multiple angles whose tangent
is one and let me draw that here with a
unit circle here so when you draw a unit
circle so it's my x-axis that's my
y-axis let me draw my unit circle here
make sure you probably don't even have
to draw the unit circle because the
tangent is really much more about the
slope of the Ray created by the angle
then where it intersects the unit circle
as would be the case with sine and
cosine so if you have
so you could have this angle right over
here so let's say this is a candidate
theta where the tangent of this theta is
the slope of this line and this terminal
angle I guess you there terminal ray you
could say of the angle the other side
the initial ray is along the positive x
axis and so you could say okay the
tangent of this theta tangent of this
theta is 1 because the slope of this
line is 1 let me scroll over a little
bit well so let me write it this way so
tangent theta is equal to 1 but I can
construct another theta whose tangent is
equal to 1 by going all the way over
here and essentially going in the
opposite direction but the slope of this
line so let's call this theta - tangent
of theta 2 is also going to be equal to
1 and of course you could go down you
could go another PI radians and go back
to the original angle but those are fun
that's functionally the same angle in
terms of in terms of how where it is
relative to the positive x-axis or what
direction it points in to but this one
is fundamentally a different angle so we
do not know we do not have enough
information just given what we've been
told to know exactly which theta we're
talking about whether we're talking
about this orange theta or this mole
data so I would say to get more
information there are multiple angles
which fit this description